pensez vous qu'il est important que les
hommes disent aux femmes qu'elles sont
intelligentes
je ne sais pas si c'est important qu'ils
le disent mais c'est tout à fait
fondamental qu'il le pense à mon avis
intelligente n'est pas un mot dont on a
l'habitude je crois de se servir pour
faire un compliment
même maintenant à une femme on tourne
autour vous dit on souvent vous êtes
intelligente assez rarement
quelquefois on arrive le 10 mai très
plaisir mais assez rarement
oui on me l'a dit on me l'a dit je sais
je sais actu ans pas prétendre que c'est
vrai mais vraiment on me l'a dit souvent
oui c'est même d'ailleurs assez embêtant
par les femmes me disent que je suis
intelligent je suis contente mais quand
les hommes me disent que je suis
intelligente
ça m'inquiète beaucoup vous savez quand
on dit beaucoup de choses de moi donc
dans le fatras des choses qu'on dit on
doit dire aussi que je suis intelligente
ça m'est arrivé c'est très agréable à
entendre surtout dans mon métier parce
que j'ai l'impression d'être autre chose
qu'un pot de fleurs qu'une plante
décorative
j'espère qu'il le pense mais je préfère
qu'ils ne le disent pas qu'on me le dise
j'ai pas j'ai envie d'être mais être
intelligente surtout pour une femme je
trouverais quand on dit à une femme
c'est une femme intelligente
ça a l'air de dire pour une femme je
trouve que vous êtes intelligente et
sage aime pas on me le dit dans un temps
parce que je pense que je suis pas
complètement sûr oui on me le dit de
tant de bruit madame de fontenay quand
vous recrutez quand vous sélectionnez jo
jeune candidate en vue d'être une miss
france éventuel qu'est ce que vous leur
demandez d'abord d'être belle ou d'être
intelligente bien vous savez moi je suis
très exigeante et l'idéal c'est d'avoir
évidemment une jeune fille qui soit
jolie est aussi intelligente parce que
pour nous maintenant enfin c'est notre
but c'est que miss france soit le reflet
d'une jeune fille disant saine de corps
et d'esprit et ma foi croyez moi que
c'est pas toujours très faciles à
trouver
alors pensez vous qu'il est l'heure dix
tasses et évidemment les hommes il aime
bien dire aux femmes qu'elles sont
jolies
quel semblant qu'elle soit brune quels
sont vos yeux est ce qu'ils disent
tellement faibles qu'elles sont
intelligentes mais ce que je dis
seulement aux hommes qui sont
intelligents je suis en train de me
demander
je ne suis pas sûr qu'ils aient à le
dire je crois qu'ils et à le faire
sentir c'est toujours la même chose je
ne crois pas beaucoup aux compliments
brutaux quel qu'il soit et je peux vous
confier d'ailleurs que dans la vie
chaque fois que j'ai eu envie de séduire
un homme je me suis dit oh là là voilà à
béganne j'aimerais me faire si jamais
quand je dis me faire comprendre des
moyens d'expression plus triviale que ma
pensée voilà dégâts que j'aimerais
suivre dirons nous et bien si le gars me
dit on lorsque vous êtes intelligent de
ses cuisses et il ne viendrait pas à
l'idée de dire à un homme comme vous
êtes intelligent alors pourquoi est-ce
qu'on le dirai aux femmes s'est passé
pas tellement de leur dire vous êtes je
trouve intelligente c'est surtout il est
important surtout qu'il les traite en
personne intelligente et égal je préfère
qu il le constate leur donner des
preuves pour cela mais je préfère qu'il
me fasse sentir et sa compliment si on
roule fait je pense qu on vous le fait
auquel vous êtes sensibles venant de la
part d'hommes
c'est un compliment auquel je suis c'est
vrai sensible il faut dire la vérité
mais aussi bien d'hommes que de femmes
vous voyez aussi bien de mes enfants
c'est peut-être le compliment auquel je
suis le plus sensible mais quelle que
soit la personne de kiel compliments
viennent enfin pas plus les hommes que
les femmes
je ne sais pas mais je crois que nous
n'en sommes pas encore à l'importance de
l'intelligence et quand un homme dit à
une fille
rask était belle quand même en général
ça marche davantage
enfin je veux aller jusqu à ce qu on a
collé à mon propre personnage la
ravissante
la mignonne la charmante et cetera on
dit jamais le charmant le ravissant
intel oui évidemment ça fait plaisir
quel que soit je ne veux pas que 1000
francs soit le ca le reflet d'une femme
objet mais de la femme symbole au
contraire préférez-vous que les hommes
rendent hommage à votre beauté ou à
votre intelligence les deux moi j'aime
bien m'entendre dire les deux jeux vous
paraître manquer de modestie mais j'aime
bien qu'on me dise tuiles intelligente
parce que j'ai l'impression de servir à
quelque chose qu'il reste quelque chose
parce que la beauté que je voudrais
éphémère un disparaît très vite alors il
faut qu'il y ait quelque chose de plus
profond et quand il me rend hommage à la
beauté
il est ce que je suis vraiment pas
trappe après jolie fille mignonne quoi
baisser tout mon intelligence mon
intelligence c'est quelque chose
complètement abstrait pour moi parce que
je suis complètement idiotes sur
certaines choses
j'ai un certain instinct sur d'autres
côté à mon âge on se pose plus tellement
la question je vous dire la vérité quand
j'avais 18 ans peut-être j'aurais
répondu d'une manière différente mais
maintenant je trouve que quand on a
franchi un âge que j'ai franchi depuis
déjà un certain nombre d'années
ben on se dit que si on n'a pas
l'intelligence on n'a plus rien
m'apporter l'as n'existe pas mon
intelligence vis-à-vis des hommes est
très moyenne je préfère qu'on dise de
moi pour une femme n'est pas si mal que
ça vous pensez que les hommes dé manière
générale aime les femmes intelligentes
autrefois on disait qu non je crois
qu'on s'est beaucoup trompé en fait qu'à
il les aime peut-être pas consciemment
mais inconsciemment il aime ta voix en
face d'eux un dialogue possible
or ils ne peuvent avoir de lier le
possible qu'avec quelqu'un qui peut leur
répondre sur le même niveau
vous savez comment sont les hommes si
une femme est douce qu elle se tait qu
elle les écoute avec des grands yeux
admiratifs
il la trouve intelligent disons
franchement les choses a priori parce
qu'elle est capable de les écouter
bouche bée si au contraire une femme
s'affirme fait un peu de bruit
rouspète pour en un mot ils ont tendance
à dire c'est une virago une pasionaria
callen merde
et c est bien ça c'est un peu un réflexe
masculin de triomphateur moi je n'y peut
pas grand-chose m'enfin je le déplore
parce que l'on ne sait jamais sur quel
pied danser ou bien on est d'où on vous
ignore on pense que vous êtes juste là
pour écouter entériner ou bien on
rouspète et on est assez mal côté il dit
souvent que les femmes intelligents sont
ennuyeux je crois qu'il faut un juste
milieu il faut qu'elle soir qu'il y ait
un petit peu de beauté un petit peu
d'intelligence et un brin d'humour il
faut pas que les filles se disent après
tout les idiotes ça plaît plus
oui bien sûr qu'en moyenne les idiotes
ça plaît davantage surtout celles qui
font semblant d'être idiote mais c'est
pas une raison je crois que vous voyez
le féminisme je suis pour de toute façon
pas par l'intelligence en tout cas par
la culture par une plus grande
connaissance de tous parce que ça permet
à une femme d'avoir une situation et de
ce fait être indépendante mais le
l'intelligence ne doit pas s'accompagner
d'agressivité comme ces quelques fois le
défaut des fameuses intelligente plus on
est intelligente
puis on doit être indulgente avec les
hommes je suis s'arrêter dijon le
portrait robot de la femme exquise pour
un homme c'est une petite femme de
préférence blanc soumises agréable à
regarder
après bavarde et surtout à murat qui
maintenant dans le monde d'aujourd'hui
les hommes estime qu' il faut qu'ils
aiment
une femme qui soit jolie peut-être mais
surtout il aime pas pour ça ils ne
peuvent pas lui mais que pour ça il faut
qu'elle soit aussi intelligente cultivée
et est resté racice qu'il rassure dans
leurs amours là il paraît ya une
tradition qui dit que les hommes ont
peur des femmes intelligentes
je crois qu'il devra beaucoup plus peur
des imbéciles
ça nous inquiète un peu bien sûr avant
il était tout seul à penser qu'ils
étaient intelligents parce que nous on
n'osait rien dire
on avait plein de choses en nous mais on
ne faisait pas les montrer on n'osait
pas être qu lactée puisque le mot est à
la mode mais j'aime bien ce mot on
s'éclate trouve ça fantastique mais elle
était aussi intelligente à temps soit
elles ne le sont pas devenues les femmes
les jeunes et les femmes avon était déjà
intelligente mais elle faisait des
confitures elle sert vérité l'après midi
je crois qu'ils en a un petit peu peur
ça les effraie un peu mais de moins en
moins on est passé un peu au-dessus de
ça maintenant je crois que c'est bien
[Musique]